the Trump administration has increased
its count of children who've been
separated from their families at the
border the Department of Health and
Human Services now says it has fewer
than 3000 in custody last week it was
2047 Mireya Villarreal shows us how
federal officials are scrambling to
reunite those children with their
parents after more than 50 days apart on
helico Gonzales Garcia and her
eight-year-old daughter were reunited in
Boston Thursday afternoon the pair
seeking asylum from violence in
Guatemala were separated and detained in
Arizona after crossing into the US
illegally
it's like having someone who you know
has died and they're not coming back to
life and then suddenly they appear in
front of you Gonzalez Garcia said the
Department of Health and Human Services
has until Tuesday to reunite children
under the age of five and July 26 for
children between the ages of five and
seventeen HHS secretary Alex azar says
his office will meet the deadlines
ordered by a US District Judge who
called the family separations a chaotic
circumstance of the government's own
making a czar says more than 230 people
are now working overtime to connect
minors with verified parents including
using DNA swabs to speed up the process
despite the administration's
reunification efforts tensions remain
high but the second time this week
police in Philadelphia arrested
protesters for clashing with officers
outside an immigration and customs
enforcement office reunited but far from
safe on helico Gonzales Garcia and her
daughter will now join the backlog of
more than 300,000 pending asylum seekers
for CBS this morning media via al the
story is so complicated not just because
the records are all over the place but
the paperwork the parents have to
provide the travel cost that you have to
incur to get your child back the
question around deportation for
sponsoring families there are a lot of
hurdles beyond just the initial one
Windows of course the deepest and the
number of children is rising right now
not shrink not going it's not going that
number is not going in the right
direction